here we go with your questions on Friday
afternoons from the bard pft p.m.
podcast and as always top of the stack
the PFT p.m. posse account what do you
see happening with players and teams
that have multi year big-money contracts
if the cap has a huge drop due to a lack
of ticket sales and revenue will star /
big-money players have to be released to
get under the cap NFL and NFL PA agree
to a one-time fix etc etc I was talking
to an Asian about this earlier today and
the agent agrees with me that this is a
potential mess you take away the ticket
revenue for a full season I don't know
what the numbers are but it's safe to
say it's a shitload of money so you take
the big pile of money that is ordinarily
available to the NFL through ticket
sales and TV revenue and everything else
that they make money from and you take
out of that the shitload of money to use
a technical term that comes from ticket
sales you have a lot less money you have
huge shitload of money - smaller
shitload of money and I'm gonna see how
many times they say shitload during this
podcast but anyway it's about being in
the bar I'm just more comfortable down
here so what happens to the cap next
year well the cap is driven by the
amount of money that came through the
prior year but remember this before the
salary cap becomes finalized it is the
product of negotiation between the Union
and the league and the union has to be
thinking ahead to that conversation
because the things the other thumb may
have to do this year to live football to
be played may require agreements from
the NFLPA and one of the things the
NFLPA may want to agree to in advance is
some sort of protection as to how far
the salary cap will drop if there is no
ticket revenue at all in 2019 so you
know this is why i've been a big
advocate of thinking ahead of planning
ahead of having a specific plan for
every potential outcome and
brainstorming all of the issues that may
come up and it really does feel like
every answer you identify leads to
another series of questions as it
relates to the salary cap the NFLPA
knowing they're gonna have to agree to
things from the league this year as they
prepare for a season
the NFLPA needs to be thinking about how
to leverage that into some sort of
commitment some sort of guarantee this
is not going to be chaos next year when
it's time to set a salary cap and then
comply with the salary cap and from the
perspective of the teams they probably
don't want that flexibility to now the
teams that have earned the least they
they may not be as interested but you
know what next year if you take away
that ticket revenue if you take away
that sweet revenue if you take away the
local revenues that that flow from the
stadium right and the local revenues
that may create disparities because once
one team is selling out every week and
another team is not you take away the
ticket revenue and you may even the
playing field and I think more teams are
gonna feel pinched if you do have a
higher salary cap but lower revenues
because some of these revenues that the
really rich teams enjoy every year they
may not be there and so a team like the
Bengals whose whose profit margin ends
up shrinking because it's got the same
salary cap that every team has even the
teams are making a lot more money for
those teams next year the hit to there
margin is going to be more comparable to
the hit of the margin of the really rich
teams who are losing money because fans
aren't showing up so anyway my point is
this yes the salary cap is likely going
to go down but the NFLPA needs to
thinking needs to be thinking now about
ways to ensure that there's an agreement
from the league to maybe make it higher
because it helps the players and make it
higher for the team's perspective
because the last thing we want next year
is to have this rampant rush to cut
players and squeeze players and reduce
salaries to comply with the salary cap I
think the teams want to have the money
to spend but there's going to be a limit
to how much they want to spend because
you don't want to be operating in the
red as a business concern in 2021
because your salary cap ends up being
more than your total revenue for the
year but you know what speaking of
operating in the red this year may be
the year where they're in the red
because the salary cap was set on last
year's revenues and this year the
money's not
going to become coming in the same way
that would otherwise offset the money
spent on players so the bottom line is
this business situation isn't good for
anybody and there are going to be all
sorts of consequences and everybody
needs to be thinking ahead about what
it's going to do to next year's salary
cap because without ticket revenue it's
definitely going to be an issue all
right next question another one from the
PFT PM policy account I think the
defense will dominate the NFL's 2020
season assuming there is one like they
do at the beginning of the year while
offenses will take longer to get in sync
without the offseason thoughts well
I'd have to go back and look more
closely at what happened in 2011
because that's gonna be the most
comparable season to this one because in
2011 there was no offseason program due
to the lockout training camp started
early August and the teams got ready and
the teams went out and played and I have
a vivid recollection of Cam Newton
number one overall pick rookie no real
work was done from a team perspective
there was no zoom video conference there
was no ability to get properly ensconced
in the playbook and he came out and he
was great now maybe he was great because
it was his physical ability that was
shining through when maybe teams weren't
as ready from an offensive or defensive
perspective as they otherwise would be
and I think about the quarterbacks who
were very good at improvising on the fly
like a Patrick mahomes it may help him
but think about this factor before we
assume that defenses are gonna have an
advantage if there are no fans the
offense in the road game is going to
have a built-in advantage because you
will never have to worry about noise
that forces you to go to the silent
count that gives the defense of the home
team that edge when everyone is going on
movement the defense picks up that
split-second advantage that otherwise
goes to the offense one
second but it's a big difference when
you can get out of your stance and begin
the process of bracing for the pass rush
that's gone when it's really loud and
you're the road team all of a sudden
that's no longer a factor places like
Seattle New Orleans Minnesota the oh the
opposing offense is gonna have an edge
and we may see more yardage and more
scoring in those circumstances and also
I I feel like especially for home teams
you know the defense gets lathered up
and I think the defense feeds on that
crowd they can take the crowd out of the
game and it becomes more surgical and it
becomes more like a scrimmage and it
becomes more like you know a seven on
seven and I just feel like that raw
energy that comes from the crowd
disappearing especially for the home
team's defense that that's gonna that's
gonna result in more yardage more
scoring and higher scoring game so I'm
not ready to say the defense is gonna
have an edge I think if anything I think
the offense is gonna have the edge
leapers 500 which teams are going to be
hurt the most by the virtual draft
process this question keeps coming up
and look I just keep going back to big
cats theory that dysfunctional teams do
dysfunctional things and we know who the
dysfunctional teams are I don't need to
name names some of the helmets are the
dysfunctional teams maybe over my
shoulder to the left or to the right we
know who the dysfunctional teams are and
to the extent that the rules are
different to the extent that this new
process requires extra discipline for
people who are working at home and think
about that all of a sudden the guys who
thrive on being at the office the guys
who are away from family the guys who
are away from the temptation to do other
things take a little work break hit the
refrigerator get a little snack take a
little rest
go outside write all of the things that
you're used to doing when you're at home
are there while you're trying to work
and you're a guy who's been so immersed
in his work he's never had to worry
about those temptations when the other
wise should be working
the dysfunctional teams are more likely
to have employees you're going to give
in to those temptations and maybe not
work as hard as they otherwise would
have or could have in preparing for the
draft you know we talked the other day
about the Virtua process of getting a
prospect on the phone or getting him on
zoom' and when you can talk to an
unlimited number of players up to three
times per week an hour at a time it
takes a lot of discipline and some teams
have that discipline and some teams
don't and I think the best teams the
hardest-working teams the most creative
teams the most organized teams those
teams aren't going to suddenly lose that
Club and at the other end of the
spectrum the teams that don't have those
attributes aren't going to suddenly gain
them right this isn't going to be the
moment of Epiphany where an organization
that is chronically bad all of a sudden
wakes up and says we got to get our act
together no you're just gonna have more
examples of why you aren't one of the
most competitive teams while the teams
that are the most competitive we're
going to show us and remind us why so I
just think that the good teams are gonna
find a way to do it right and the bad
teams are gonna find a way to do it
wrong and it really is that simple it's
just a question from Sando shuffle
did you beef with Peter King off camera
after he said that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard no that goes back to our
conversation from PFC live today
regarding the Odell Beckham jr. trade
report that came out on Wednesday from
mark my losses of WFAN and Peter's
argument was that he would have taken it
more seriously if someone like Chris
Mortensen
had reported it on Wednesday and my
response to Peter and I was diplomatic
as I could be I could have taken the low
groan I could have said something about
the 11 of 12 footballs from and maybe I
did during the break and maybe he got
through to the podcast as apparently
that happened but I chose to be
professional for a change and my point
was if you are somebody who breaks news
on a regular basis if you're Chris
Morrison Adam Schefter
Jay Glazer Ian Rapoport any other
national insiders or even somebody just
covers a team
you're gonna get things wrong from time
to time you're gonna get burned by a
source from time to time you're gonna
have a source that you trust who is just
factually incorrect either that source
got something wrong or that source had
an agenda and is willing to play that
card and hope that that source can act
you ask you for forgiveness after that
but the case maybe if you're somebody
who does this for a living and this was
my point to Peter
you're gonna have more scoops behind it
so you're gonna be more willing to take
a chance with something that may be
wrong because if you are wrong you've
got a quick chance to redeem yourself
let me share with you an example I
picked up from Howard Stern's book of
the interview excerpts Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Fallon explained to him that he
used to be far more tormented after a
Saturday Night Live though the way he
wanted because he had to wait a whole
week for the next one but on tonight's
show
if you screw something up you got
another one coming tomorrow
it's easier to get over so if you're a
reporter and maybe you make a mistake
maybe you trust a source when you
shouldn't you can get over it quickly
because you're gonna be right back on
the horse reporting something else but
when your mark my losses of WFAN who to
my knowledge has never reported anything
that registered on the NFL's radar
screen as relates to the never ending
cycle of news name never stood out for
any reason and frankly the only reason I
recognized the name as I was on his
weekend show with Maggie gray a couple
of weeks ago otherwise I'd have been
like who the hell is Mark malucia's
Franklin but if you're gonna be that guy
and you're gonna swing that axe one time
and that's what you're gonna be known
for you're gonna get it right
unleash you're gonna be damn sure you
got it right and I continue to believe
that the reason this got out was that
the Vikings were talking to the Giants
about Odell Beckham jr. and that's
somebody from the Giants hoping to screw
it all up let me think about it if
you're the Giants if you're the Giants
and you catch wind of the Vikings
talking to the Browns about a trade for
Odell Beckham jr. okay the Browns are
gonna get some sort of value for Beckham
jr. now maybe you want the Browns to
flush the Odell Beckham jr. experiment
so you look better for getting up on him
last year or maybe maybe you don't want
to go back on jr. back in the conference
there was talk last year that the Giants
took less from the Browns and they could
have got from the 49ers because they
want him out of the conference maybe the
Giants don't want
oh no Beckham jr. on the bike maybe the
Giants don't want Hotel Beckham jr. to
be in a place where there's a greater
chance he's going to be the kind of
player they
was with the Giants maybe you prefer to
have him with a dysfunctional team
because dysfunctional teams do
dysfunctional things whatever the case
may be I'm a firm believer there was
something to this and I tried to explain
to Peter during a show and what he said
was after it made my case that's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard and look
it makes for good TV it makes for good
audio and I ultimately said him saying
it was the dumbest thing he's ever heard
is the dumbest thing I've ever heard he
had a big glass and all that but I
believe based upon the things I heard
and I believe based upon the tentacles
that I put out there and trying to find
out if there's anything to it I believe
there was something to it and it's quite
possible that as with Wednesday there
was something to it
and the fact it got out caused it all to
disintegrate and it's possible that
there could be something to it next week
and look it's entirely possible to Paul
DePodesta when you have a conference
call yesterday that's completely false
was lying through his teeth because news
flash folks these teams will for
strategic reasons lie through their
teeth we've seen it before we'll see it
again
we have no intent to trade Percy Harvey
how many times we have to hear jail and
Ramsey isn't gonna be traded how many
times do we hear last year that our
Beckham jr. wasn't it betrayed by the
Giants how many times do we have to be
lied to before we recognize in advance
that what they're telling us now could
be wait for it a lie so that's the point
I was trying to make to Peter and one of
the fundamental disagreements Peter and
I have from time to time is he tends to
take things at face value more than I do
I'm more inclined to scratch the surface
and say there's a chance that's [ __ ]
so he can have the opinion that my
theory is the dumbest thing he's ever
heard and I can have the opinion that
he's taking something at face value that
he shouldn't will sit
but even if photon Beckham jr. isn't
ready to the Vikings that doesn't mean
there was nothing to it and I tend to
think that if Mark Moe looses unless all
of a sudden he is doing a mid-career
pivot from radio host to NFL news
breaker and he's going to have more and
more and more of these tweets
unless he's decided to undergo that
organic change to his NFL or sports
career this is the one thing he's going
to be remembered for and I think it's
unfortunate
we just write him off as some radio
goofball who just got something wrong
why in the hell would you take the
chance on something like this
if you think that it may be wrong
alright moving right along PFT sponge a
question that made me laugh when I
scrolled through this earlier and yes I
will admit this is one of the days where
I scroll through it in advance because
it's kind of different down here at the
barn and I want to have it to make up
slightly more organized there's one
thing I hop on if I'm just doing audio I
can fumble around a little bit more
because you can't see the look on my
face as I'm kind of like going what the
hell am I going to say next so I'm gonna
be slightly more organized and slightly
more professional even though I'm down
here in the whiskey and cigar hanging
out anyway I did look at some of these
in advance PFT sponge asks when football
returns do you think we'll see
quarterbacks licking their fingers and
hands or possibly now all players that
touch the ball will all wear gloves look
I think we still will see the
quarterbacks licking their fingers in
their hands because no one's gonna be
out on a field unless they've been
tested before the game that they are
corona virus negative and this is
something else Peter and I were arguing
about today because
I'm a firm believer that the NFL's
last-ditch scenario is going to be
creating some sort of a sequestered
environment where players are
essentially quarantined in a hotel away
from their families Peter thinks that as
he reads what dr. fouled she said the
other day it's not at that point yet and
players will be tested once a week when
they're living at home I don't think
that would be good enough if the players
are living at home I think that they
need to be tested before they walk
through the door every single day
because all it takes is that one guy to
go into the locker room positive with
coronavirus one guy and in that locker
room you're gonna have I'm not gonna say
every guy but potentially every guy
think about a locker room if you've ever
been in one you probably wish you had
it's dirty its smelly it's close
quarters the virus has spread quickly
bacteria spreads quickly mold spreads
quickly State spreads quickly so if you
really guys go home guys who have kids
if people are back in school then and
hung up who knows what's gonna happen
between now and September if you turn on
the news
you'll hear every possible theory in 15
minutes but if the world is back to
normal before it should be back to
normal and kids are bringing home the
corona virus from school and dad was
tested on Sunday at the facility before
the game dad's gonna have to be tested
on Monday when he goes back for film
study dad's gonna have to be tested on
Wednesday when he goes back for practice
he's gonna have to be tested on Thursday
when he goes back for practice you're
gonna have to test these guys every time
they show up before they walk in the
door it's not gonna be enough to take
their temperature cuz you can have the
disease and have no symptoms you can be
positive with no symptoms so that basic
screening of taking someone's
temperature doesn't mean anything if
this is somebody who gets no symptoms
from it so my point is this if we get to
the point where guys are gonna be
playing
they will have been tested before
they're plying specifically because guys
you're gonna want to go out and just
play and not think about they're gonna
lick their fingers before they throw the
ball and you're gonna have virus on the
ball and the ball is gonna get thrown
the guy was gonna catch it if he wearing
gloves it's gonna be on his gloves it's
gonna be on everything he touches if if
he catch the ball at the quarterback
leaked his hand touch the ball through
the ball receiver catches it gloves on
the ball virus on the gloves gloves on
the helmet gloves on the shirt gloves
everywhere you're gonna have the virus
that's why it spreads through a locker
room so quick so anyway I listen I like
the fact that there's a sense of
positivity I like the fact that they are
brainstorming ways to have football
season but it does not take a lot for me
to get to the point where I conclude
it's going to be impractical to have a
football season unless you sequester the
players or we have a procedure where
people can be tested every single day on
the way in and maybe on the way out
great I don't know how difficult it's
gonna be I don't know what testing
procedure is gonna be available the
tests that they have initially you stick
a thing up your nose and like through
back to your brain I'd like to think
it's progressed some since then and I'd
like to think it would progress even
more by the time we get to September but
these are very real factors that need to
be kept in mind as the NFL tries to
figure out what in the hell it's
actually going to do all right let's see
what we have next year Charles wants to
know is there any actual logic behind
the one helmet rule apparently the one
helmet rule could go away in 2021 I
don't understand the one helmet rule
other than it kills fun the NFL's idea
that having each player where only one
helmet all year long not one helmet mark
one helmet and only that helmet
you're not allowed to have two of the
same helmet so you can't have one that
is black and you can't have one that is
yellow which is good for the Steelers
because I hated that yellow moment that
they were when you were allowed to have
multiple helmets but what it does is it
takes away the throw backs and this all
came out because a couple of weeks ago
Bruce Arians was on Dan Patrick show and
he said it like it was gospel truth that
the Buccaneers will be able to wear next
year the creamsicle uniforms because
they can wear a white helmet to go along
with the pewter helmet and back over my
shoulder somewhere there is both the
white helmet I think the white helmets
back here and the pewter helmets back
there but as long as the one helmet was
in place you can't do it the NFL told me
they haven't made a decision yet I still
don't know what the logic is when you
consider that at the college level
different helmet every week for some of
these teams I don't understand where the
safety component comes into play
if it's an approved helmet design why do
you have to have the same one every week
if it's the exact same helmet why does
it matter if it's not the same how about
your war last week if it's the same
helmet and if it's all fitted the same
way it shouldn't matter so I don't know
if there isn't a logic I just think that
the NFL at one point was so concerned
about creating the impression that it is
doing everything it can to promote
player health and safety as relates to
brain health that the NFL decided we're
gonna go with this one helmet and only
one helmet thing because that's just
another thing we can point to to say
we're doing everything we can to keep
players as healthy as we possibly can
all right next question
let's see what else we had up here
j-train 33 with the team's doing a
technical mock draft party draft do you
think teens will use this as a
smokescreen to hide their to their true
draft boards look I I don't think we're
gonna hear any team saying actual real
names from the 20/20 class I think maybe
what they should do is go back and redo
last year's draft and havoc teams go in
the order of of the picks they made then
and they just name those names or they
send out a laundry list of fake names
maybe cartoon characters or something
like that but that this isn't going to
be a mock draft in the sense that when
the bengals are on the clock there
pick Joe burrow I don't think that's
what they mean by mock drafts so I don't
think there's going to be any part of
this and I'll try to find out how they
actually go about it what names are they
using because they're surely not going
to use actual names from the 20 20 draft
class that's something that a GM
rightfully should be able to complain
about if they're saying yeah I just
thought let's just go ahead and pick one
of the names in and well we'll just
pretend that it's all fake I mean it's
it's it's ludicrous to even go down that
path to the NFL all right a red zone up
or good friend from across the Atlantic
Ocean wants to know if a trouble-free
draft next week would change the process
forever I don't know that it will I
don't know we're gonna fall in love with
the stay-at-home draft I think that it's
not going to be a replacement for the
excitement of having tens of thousands
of people pressed now here's the thing
next year where every draft is going to
be and I think they picked the location
for 2021 and 2023 once Kansas City one
is Cleveland 2022 that may be when Las
Vegas gets its crack at doing what it's
not going to do this year I think the
NFL is gonna have to ask itself by next
April will we be at a point where people
will show up in enough numbers then it
becomes a good visual that's the only
reason they're doing because think back
to the images from Philadelphia a few
years ago how stunning that was the
first night of the draft to see 80,000
people there it looks good on TV that's
what it's all about
that's what this all is it's a TV show
it's a TV show that's all about nothing
because the whole thing could be done
the way they're gonna do it it could be
done by text message it could be done by
open conference call where one team
picks after another you don't need the
pomp and circumstance you don't need the
pageant for you don't need the players
there you don't need the bear hug with
the Commissioner so I don't know let's
see how it goes next week it may not be
exactly like what we see next week going
forward but there may be elements of
what comes out of next week that become
part of the draft as we move forward
into 2021 and beyond let's see how it
looks next week and let's see what parts
of it we decide maybe are better than
what it used to be and hell I already
can't remember how it used to be I've
been thinking so much about how it's
going to be I forget
how it used to be it used to be a must
people sitting around a desk and a bunch
of cameras in war rooms and a bunch of
guys walking out with their suits on
hugging the Commissioner shaking hands
with the commissioner lifting off the
ground or whatnot and is gonna be very
different this [ __ ] alright let's see
what else we have here
Mike likes dirt and let's know if you
could be a scout or an assistant coach
for NFL team which role would you choose
and why well this was very simple for me
I don't want to be an assistant coach I
being a scout is a thankless job being a
scout entails a lot of Treasury a lot of
travel a lot of going to crappy hotels
and crappy towns and chasing down
information about college football
players and kissing the asses of college
football coaches who can beat butt holes
from time to time I wouldn't want that
job you toil in anonymity and you maybe
if you're lucky work your way up the
ranks there's a lot of guys who spend
their whole careers just grinding and
grinding and grinding on the road all
the time I don't want that now assistant
coaches are going to work their asses
off but they're going to beat the team
facility they get to go home at night
sleep in a bed they get to be with their
families right you're traveling with the
team you're with the team and you know
for me and Tony Dungy and I have had
these conversations one of the things I
think I would been really good at his
taking film and breaking it down and
finding the clues finding the tendencies
finding the tells finding the little
things I've had conversations with Chris
Spielman he was on pft live years ago
and we talked about the things he would
pick up when studying film I think that
my attention to detail is such that I
would find that stuff I would find that
moment where the quarterback licks his
fingers before it's a pass by I mean
those are the most basic ones we've
heard about before but you know it's
almost like one of those one of those
games I always loved those games where
you've got two pictures and five things
are different between the two pictures I
always loved those when I was a kid
because I can find them I could focus in
I could find that detail and I could see
what's different and looking at all the
plays over and over and over again it
would be a challenge find what's
different find what's different fun at
the common thread is I'd love that I
still want to do that now because that'd
be gonna be good at but so I would want
to be an assistant coach because I just
think
standpoint of film study and finding
those clues that let you know ahead of
time what the play is going to be that's
one thing I think I would have been good
at I may have been terrible at
everything else I may have been a
horrible teacher of technique I may have
been horrible at coming up with game
plans but the one thing I would have
been able to do I think at a very high
level is find the clues in the plays
that teams are run in the past that
would tell us in real-time what to look
for before the snap when your defense is
out there what is the offense doing that
is giving us an idea of what this play
is going to be all right let's see what
else we have on tour forever do you
think we'll see any big trades in day
one or day two of the draft considering
all teams have their reps at home
individually I don't think it's gonna be
any different when it comes to trades
now I think we could see teams that are
more willing to trade up and trade other
pics because let's say they've gotten
the point where there's a small handful
of guys they love there's a small
handful of guys that they have to have
and they're gonna do what they have to
do to get those guys and if they have to
give up draft picks if they have to give
up multiple draft picks that would be
used under circumstances where they
don't have that same level of comfort
that they love a guy because they
weren't able to work the guy up the wind
for the West one maybe they're willing
to make that move that's why I continue
to be fascinated by the possibility of
the Dolphins trading up with the Bengals
I look at so much of what's coming out
as we approach the draft from both teams
perspectives as just part of the
smokescreen effort to get everyone to
think that the Bengals aren't budging
and the Dolphins aren't budging and it
may be part of a broader dance to get
the Bengals to offer more or the
Dolphins to take less and I'm looking
for those close because I think at the
end of the day Steven Ross the owner the
Dolphins may I let's be real about this
and I addressed this earlier today on
radio in Miami with Joe Rosen Zack
Krantz and I think I've talked about it
elsewhere on radio this week and it's
somewhat indelicate but as Simms would
say I'm just gonna go ahead and say it
Stephen Ross is old he's gonna be 80
soon if he's not already 80 and if
you've got 5 to 7 to 10 years left where
you know you're gonna be in a good
faculties and you're gonna get to enjoy
the games and you're gonna be functional
right and who knows maybe May
he's able to go past 90 but if I want to
bring of 80 I'm not assuming I have more
than 10 years of good years where I'm
going to be fully engaged with my
business interests and god bless him for
being almost 80 or already 80 and having
the ability to be fully engaged with
business interests but I'm gonna be more
inclined to give the bangles what they
want to get them to give me Joe burrow
if as I've heard over and over again
Stephen Ross loves Joe burrow and if
I've seen what those draft picks I'm
giving up have turned into over the
course of the last ten years or so that
I've owned a team right we pissed away
plenty of draft picks we've swung and
missed on plenty of guys but this is a
guy I want this is the guy I want to be
the quarterback of my team for the 10
years that I have left and I am 10 as a
highly functioning individual who's able
to fully appreciate the fruits of my
labor
let's get your borough let's do what we
have to do let's make the Bengals an
offer they can't refuse now adding to
the intrigue here
the fact that the Bengals are so
unpredictable like they don't know
what's good for them like well they know
an offer that they can't refuse when
it's staring them in the face or are
they so dysfunctional
I'm sorry Bengals but I have to go there
are they so dysfunctional they won't
know that they should take that offer
and maybe they get more that way maybe
the Bengals will be that that guy that
that despite himself just kind of Bluffs
his way into a far better deal than the
otherwise would have had just because he
doesn't know what's good for that's what
I'm fascinated by and to get back to the
broader point
because teams haven't had the chance to
fully fall in love with the full
complement of players the way they
ordinarily would if they have some guys
they're sold on that they believe or
can't miss you may have that willingness
to move up because who cares about the
picture give it up because when it's
time to use those picks you know that's
how you're gonna do anyway all right
let's see what else we have here I may
want to end on that one I kind of liked
that one I'm trying to find one more I'm
in that mode let's find one more one
more
on tour forever wants to know if there
any new network or streaming shows I've
really gotten into right now you know my
wife and I have been watching better
call Saul let me say this about better
call Saul it's gotten very good lately I
really do feel like though that better
call Saul for as well written and acted
as it is it it's plotting at times not
t-d it just moves slowly and I find
myself every time a new season starts
forgetting what had happened the prior
season even though I watched all the
episodes and like when the latest season
of better call Saul started I went back
and watched all of the shows from the
last season because I really did forget
a lot of stuff and Breaking Bad that
never happened when Breaking Bad I never
needed a refresher I remember all the
storylines all the plot lines all the
subplots they may resonate and maybe
that's the biggest indictment a better
call saw the characters are memorable
because we already knew who they were
the one lingering question is what
happens to Kim and every once in a while
they make us think is Kim gonna die
right now you've got this story I don't
want to give away any spoilers but the
bottom line is there isn't a whole lot
of guesswork because we know that Saul
lives we know that Mike lives now every
once in a while they do the
flash-forward to where Saul was working
at the Cinnabon and he's been outed by
someone and where is that all gonna end
and gonna tie together and I have a
theory of what's autumn Utley gonna
happen I'm not gonna share it now
because there may be some people out
there who are watching it who are behind
by a few episodes but that that's one
show we're watching but I find myself
really struggling to stay in game the
last couple of episodes though I haven't
had a struggle I thought the last two
episodes were very very good and the
season finale is coming up and maybe the
last season
which is coming up whenever the last
season is ready to go hopefully it's
going to end with a bang and it's going
to be memorable as memorable with
Breaking Bad was other other shows or
watching what are we watching Jill and I
started watching little fires everywhere
on Hulu the first episode was really
good it feels like it's just kind of
gradually like less and less interesting
to me as it goes along we just I you
know once you swim you stuff when do you
check out there are shows where and I
did this with a walking deck like The
Walking Dead I thought the first season
was written and the second season there
were episodes where I remember having it
on TiVo at the time was it team oh it
was like eight nine years ago and I
wouldn't fast-forward through the
commercials because I needed a break it
was so intense I wanted to have a few
minutes where I could collect myself
before we went right back into it but
then I got to a point after three four
or five seasons where it's like they
don't follow this anymore I don't
understand what's going on and I really
don't like it anymore but I have to keep
watching it because I've been watching
it all along like you have to do justice
to the time you've already invested so
you keep going I eventually got to a
partner's head screw it undone and my
guess is based upon the numbers The
Walking Dead generates now relative to
what The Walking Dead used to generate a
lot of people decided they had enough
and that's unfortunate you know that's
what Jerry Seinfeld wanted to do when
his series ended he wanted to go out on
a high note and as much as I love that
series I think he's convinced himself he
went out on a high note I don't think he
did I think that there were episodes the
last season that were not good and if
you watch the series back to back to
back to back to back and I've been
watching it you can see the progression
from how they find their footing to when
they find their groove season for the
best season five underrated they were
still really in that bubble by the time
they get to 7 8 9 and I know at some
point Larry David left um
but you really start the sense man this
isn't what it used to be and by the time
you
last season yes the last season has its
moments a lot of those episodes man
they're not good and the finale I don't
care what they were trying to do and I
know there's a small percentage of
people out there that love the finale
I thought the finale was not good and
but but he went out before you really
got to the point where people were
saying why the hell are we still
watching this so he did go out on a high
note
apparently he turned down a shitload I
got to do it one more time of money to
keep doing it even though that tenth
season may have been an embarrassment to
the brand The Walking Dead stayed around
way too long other shows stay around way
too long I guess that's my point you
have to know when to shut up
and move on on that note I'm gonna shut
up and move on we'll see you Monday for
pft live we'll be posting all weekend
long and pro football talk on we have
our one and only mock draft coming you
know I don't do ten versions anymore cuz
everybody's got a mock draft and nobody
really knows and I know it sets the
stage for conversation we'll have our
one and only mock draft at some point
before the draft begins although it
would be a lot more accurate if I waited
until after the draft started anyway
full draft coverage over the weekend
next week is gonna be a lot of fun I'm
gonna go ahead and say this now because
it may only be three of you left
watching and I'm running the risk of a
jinx here I think we're gonna have Jill
Barrow on Monday and I think we're gonna
do it down here in the barn everybody
enjoy your weekend we'll see you on
Monday morning for a new PFT live maybe
Monday afternoon for a PFT p.m. with Jo
burrow and either way stories and
content analysis rooms the Laura Pro
Football Talk comm have a great weekend
stay safe
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports